[Music]
if therefore religion is the perfection
of spirit into which its individual
moments
consciousness self-consciousness reason
and spirit return
and have returned as into their ground
they together constitute the existent
actuality of the totality
of spirit which is only as the
differentiating and self-returning
movement of these its aspects
the genesis of religion in general is
contained in the movement of the
universal moments
but since each of these attributes was
exhibited not
merely as it determines itself in
general
but as it is in and for itself that is
as it runs its course as a totality
within
itself therefore what has come to be is
not merely the genesis
of religion in general
those complete processes of the
individual aspects
at the same time contain these specific
forms of religion itself the totality of
spirit
the spirit of religion is again the
movement
away from its immediacy towards the
attainment of the knowledge
of what it is in itself or immediately
the movement in which
finally the shape in which it appears
for its consciousness will be perfectly
identical with its essence
and it will behold itself as it is in
this genesis of religion
spirit itself therefore assumes specific
shapes which constitute the different
moments of this movement at the same
time the specific religion has likewise
a specific
actual spirit thus if consciousness
self-consciousness reason and spirit
belonging to self-knowing spirit in
general
similarly the specific shapes which were
specially
developed within consciousness
self-consciousness reason and spirit
belong to the specific shapes of
self-knowing spirit
from the shapes belonging to each of its
moments
the specific shape of religion picks out
the one appropriate to it
for its actual spirit the one
distinctive feature which characterizes
the religion penetrates every aspect of
its actual existence
and stamps them with this common
character
in paragraph 680 hegel is continuing
with his explanation of
where this new religion section fits
in the totality of the phenomenology of
spirit and and why
a religion section is needed
since we've already talked about
religion a bit in the four
previous sections of the
phenomenology and this is a important
turning point
right here he's finally starting to tell
us
how do the things if we look ahead in
the chapter
how do these specific shapes and
movements or developments in the
religion section
how are they not just replicating
what has gone before so he tells us
if religion is the perfection the
follendong right the
bringing to fulfillment of spirit in
which it's individual moments and that's
what these
long sections have been consciousness
self-consciousness reason and spirit
return and have returned as into their
their ground they've attained
their their point they together
and so that's an important thing you
know we've talked about this already
they together
constitute the existent actuality of the
totality of spirit now that's an
interesting
term to use here there's a lot of
philosophical jargon all packed
into that almost as if you know each one
is intensifying
the other so let's actually start at the
the
back part of it right the totality of
spirit so you notice that spirit is one
of these
sections but spirit is also like the
overarching
totality of what's going on spirit or
mind geist
and we've got the totality
uh in this case it's in the the genitive
does ganson geisters right
of the the entire uh the entirety the
totality the the whole shebang you could
say
of of spirit or mind whatever geist is
revealing itself to be through us as as
parts of it or as moments of it right
so you know in previous paragraphs he
talked about a number of different
totalities
and he used the word totalite there
instead of
gans so we want to be a little bit
attuned to that
but existent actuality so
zionist vehicle kite it's tempting to
say
especially for those for whom you know
existence is not a predicate
that does indus and you know
vehicle kidneys or anything like that
would essentially be equivalent but
clearly for hegel there's not there's
something
more being added by it being an
actuality that is an existent
actuality it's coming forth into
uh not being as such but rather our as
phenomenologists are realizing
that this is what's going on and he says
this is only the difference
as the differentiating and
self-returning movement of these its
aspects so you know typical hegelian
stuff here
differentiating self-returning movement
this is part of the
uh hegelian approach to things right we
see how things break into their sections
what their relations are where the
conflicts lie
and then there's a movement and this is
the movement from you know certainty to
truth and back to
truth and certainty it's the movement
from the in itself to the for
itself then the in and for itself right
so he goes on and he says um the genesis
of religion in general
and i'm not super happy with
translating verden the verdundes
religion uh as genesis
i guess you know the when we think of
genesis
okay in the classic sense it means the
coming to be okay so that is
in its greek terminology basically the
same thing as verden
in this case but we also tend to think
of genesis as like the
origin point and i think that could be a
bit
misleading here for some readers so you
want to think
instead of thinking origin point as
genesis you want to think process of
coming into being
genesis so he says the the the genesis
of religion
in general is contained in the movement
of the universal
moments and what's the you know that's
this stuff that's been happening already
but since each of these attributes was
exhibited not merely as it determines
itself in general
but as it is in and for itself and so
how is he explaining that
as it runs its course as a totality
within itself so
each of these has been a totality
spirit was a totality the section spirit
um
reason was as well self-consciousness
consciousness each of them
has been this totalizing
movement where spirit is getting to know
itself
better in the process and they're not
you know linked like
well first spirit goes through
consciousness and only then does it
arrive
at self-consciousness and only then does
it arrive at reason
uh it's not it's not quite so neat and
clear is that
so he says as it runs its course as a
totality within itself
therefore what has come to be is not
merely the
genesis of religion in general uber
helped
these complete processes of the
individual aspects
what now we're back here the individual
aspects of spirit or
reason or self-consciousness or
consciousness we might think
you know the unhappy consciousness and
self-consciousness
we might think of i mean it depends on
how you want to look at force and the
understanding
that could there could be a little bit
of religious stuff going on in there
there might even be some religious stuff
going on in reason even though hegel
said it wasn't there's definitely
religious stuff going on
in spirit these are specific forms
of religion itself or at least
we've seen prefigurations of them in the
specific shapes
that are that are going on within these
developments
so he goes on and he says the totality
of spirit
the spirit of religion is again the
movement away from
immediacy towards knowledge of what it
is
in itself or immediately the movement in
which
finally the shape gestalt in which it
appears for consciousness
will be perfectly identical with its
essence and it will behold itself as it
is
is that actually going to happen in
religion yes
in a way in the end in the revealed
religion
it's really going to happen in absolute
knowing
and you could say that since the you
know the preface is
uh essentially written later to you know
correspond to the absolute knowing
what's going on in the preface
kind of fits into that as well so
what's really important here though is
he says here we go
in this genesis of religion spirit
assumes specific shapes which constitute
the different moments of
this movement so that's why we have a
section here that's why we're going to
be moving
very shortly to the first main section
natural religion
and then we're going to have god as
light and then we're going to have plant
and animal
then we're going to have the artificer
each of those is a
gestalt each of those is a specific
bizandra a determinant
shape is another way we can translate it
so
religion itself is going to have new
shapes that haven't been talked about
but could be connected with things
things back here and he goes on and he
says
um at the same time the specific
religion
so we see these specific religions think
specific shape
right uh is a specific
actual has likewise a specific actual
spirit so
when we're thinking about religion of
light where he's talking about for
example zoastronism
all right that's a specific shape there
is a
spirit to that there is a a
determinate you know organic working
itself out
that in a way hasn't been in this except
implicitly perhaps so he says
if consciousness self-consciousness
reason and spirit
belong to self-knowing spirit in general
similarly the specific shapes which were
specifically developed within
consciousness self-consciousness reason
and spirit belong to specific shapes of
self-knowing
spirit so you know nothing really that
surprising
in there at each of the the points you
know we can call them
gestalts we can call them dynamics and
this kind of
answers the question of well what good
is the the phenomenology
given that like history didn't end as
hegel was going to claim and
some of the other things might seem to
be kind of kind of arbitrary at times
well each of them is a
shape and a way in which spirit
is actual within the world so it's it's
worth
studying them and you know this is a bit
of a side note but
here hegel is also in a way addressing
the question of
why should we do comparative religion
and you know why should we study if
there is some sort of consummate
religion that we're going to talk about
as hegel does think
why should we study all this previous
stuff should it be a triumphal
you know well in the beginning there
were the animists and then there were
you know
these polytheists and then we got to
henotheism
and then we got to you know monotheism
and that was really great and then it
was revealed in different ways you know
first judaism
and then christianity well islam
happened afterwards but
we're not going to worry about that or
let alone sikhism
and you know this sort of like i use the
word triumphalistic it means
where you're saying the religious
comportment and understanding that we
have this is the best all the other
stuff is leading up to it
or veering off from it and it's there's
a nice developmental picture there
we can also do comparative religion in
other ways
and this is not exactly what hegel is is
advocating he is
you know saying christianity and
specifically protestant christianity
uh is you know at the apex of of
development
um and and to be honest his treatment of
other religions is kind of sketchy
but there's there's possibilities for
something like a hegelian
against hegel comparative treatment of
things
where we would look at each religion as
being a way in which spirit
has in some way manifested itself and we
could still preserve a higher and lower
or you know
development thing we would just say well
there isn't just only one single
developmental
path all right so digression ended back
to this
so he says from the shapes belonging to
each of its moments the specific
shape of religion picks out the one
appropriate to it for its actual
spirit the one distinctive feature which
characterizes the religion
penetrates every aspect of its actual
existence and stamps them with this
common character
so what we've seen in all of these
dialectical developments let's think
about what was going on
for example in reason right when when
the spirit was trying to think of
ethical life
and the you know the zaka zelps the
whatever we want to translate that is
not just the thing in itself but the
project
you know what am i as a human being and
it went into
you know the law of the heart and frenzy
of self-conceit
there was a determinant shape there and
that pervades the entirety
of the the person and the society's
existence
it's not everything that's going on but
it pervades it right
similarly in religion as we're now going
to be
sketching it out as yet another
long dynamic not as long of course as
spirit and reason
we are going to get specific shapes like
that and each of them
is a totality it pervades
the existence the life the community the
thought of the people who are within
that religion
seeking worshipping acting doing all of
these things
just as much as the unhappy
consciousness and the multiple
modes that it took in that determinate
shape of consciousness
did in fact pervade that as well so
that's that's what's going on here
in this way the arrangement of the
shapes which have hitherto appear
differs from the way they have appeared
in their own order
on this point we shall observe briefly
at the start what is necessary
in the series we considered each moment
exploring its own depths formed itself
into a totality
within its own peculiar principle and
cognition was the depth
or the spirit wherein the moments which
have no other subsistence
of their own possessed their substance
but this substance is now manifest it is
the depth of spirit that is certain of
itself which does not allow the
principle of each individual moment
to become isolated and to make itself a
totality within itself
on the contrary gathering and holding
together all these moments within itself
it advances within this total wealth of
its actual spirit
and all its particular moments take and
receive in common to the into themselves
the like determinateness of the whole
this
self-certain spirit and its movement is
their true actuality
and the being in and for our self which
belongs to each moment
thus while the previous single series
and its advance marked the retrogressive
steps in it by nodes
but continued itself again from them in
a single line
it is now as it were broken at those
nodes
at these individual moments and falls
apart into many lines
which gathered up into a single bundle
at the same time combined
symmetrically so that the similar
differences in which
each particular moment took shape within
itself meet together
however it is self-evident from the
whole exposition how this coordination
of the general directions here
represented is to be understood
so that it is superfluous to remark that
these differences are to be grasped
essentially
only as moments of the development not
as parts in actual spirit
there are attributes of its substance
but in religion on the other hand
they are only predicates of the subject
similarly all forms in general are
certainly in themselves or for us
contained in spirit and in each spirit
but as regards spirit's actuality the
main point is solely which
determinateness is explicit for it in
its consciousness
in which determinateness it has
expressed itself
or in which shape it knows its essence
paragraph 681 is continuing
this discussion of religions relation to
the
previous series sequences whatever we
want to call them
in which spirit was developing itself
and we notice
that there's there's an interplay here
between
how things appeared to us as the
phenomenologists
going through all the previous material
in a section or in a suck session
and how it's supposed to be for us at
this point
as the phenomenologist of of spirit
and so you notice that there's a lot of
interesting
language going on in here that will
bring to light
um and you could say an overarching
metaphor that's being sketched out
so he says in this way the arrangement
of the shapes the gestalton right which
have hitherto appear differs from the
way they
appeared in their own order order
um and you know the succession is
leading us to this
series aya idea which
could be translated also as like row you
know there's a linear
function to it that he's going to
mention in just a bit
and so he says on this point we shall
observe briefly at the start
what is necessary in the series we
considered
each moment exploring its own depths
okay so
now we're getting to what's what's
happening we have a
series and there is a shape or
moment the same thing right so
a gestalt a moment and
these could be quite long these could be
very short
in number of paragraphs that are devoted
to them
but there's something that's that's key
to each one of them
they're not just little introductory
paragraphs
there's something that takes determinant
form
and develops itself and isn't just
a matter of you know like a concept
reproducing itself
it's people's minds and actions and
trying to make sense out of their lives
so the raw material
of each of these shapes and moments is
human beings and their
own understanding their cognition
of themselves their attempts to produce
some sort of
you know rationally reconciled
harmonious
stance towards the world on themselves
about things that are important and they
always fall apart they're always
you know they're always imperfect
they're always not completely
fulfilled but he does tell us something
about each one of these that's worth
thinking about
so he talks about a totality a gods
right he says
each moment exploring its own deaths
depths formed itself into a totality
so it didn't just find a totality there
it didn't have a blueprint it formed
itself into a totality it
acted it it thought it took a stance it
said yes to this and no to this
it evaluated it placed one thing higher
than
another it said i'm on the real path
here this other stuff
is is not so important it exercises the
power of the negative this is what's
been going on
right so he says formed itself into a
totality
how with own it's within its own
peculiar principle princip
right its own particular
way of understanding things and this is
very much the way that hegel
treats the development of philosophy the
development of history
if you look at his you know lectures on
these sorts of things this goes all the
way through later on to
you know social and political
discussions and you know lectures on the
philosophy of religion as well
so he tells us cognition
air cannon was the depth or the spirit
wherein the
moments which have no other subsistence
of their own possess
their substance so our canon
um you know which is going to be
exercising the mind we'll just keep it
very broad here his cognition
that's going on here and that's
happening even in things that seem to be
very superficial or completely action
oriented there is some thinking
and that is going to lead us to the
depths the genuine depths of something
else so it tells us that here we go
cognition was the depth or the spirit
where in the moments which have no other
subsistence possessed their
substance but this substance is now
manifest now we know what was actually
happening all this time
it is the depth of spirit that is
certain of itself which is developed
through the
spirit section of the work and now is
what we're engaging with here at the
beginning part of religion before we're
actually talking about any real
religions
any substantive shapes of religion to
take what we were talking about last
paragraph
so he says it's the spirit that's
certain of itself which does not allow
the principle
the principle that each individual
moment has
to become isolated and make it a
totality within itself
well that's what was been going on
throughout each of these
successions hasn't it so you know we
start with for example
in self-consciousness you know all this
discussion about life
and self-consciousness and then we have
the two self-consciousnesses encounter
each other
and they could get stymied and stop
there right they have this struggle to
the death
and you know maybe that's a little
arbitrary maybe that doesn't have to
happen that way
but let's say that they do in fact need
to struggle to the death
one could kill the other okay now we
begin the cycle again
they could both kill each other or we
have something new happen
we have one of the give in
to its fear and thereby give itself over
to the the other self-consciousness
which becomes the master
and the one who gave in becomes the
slave
and the slave is put to work and now
we've got a new
you know totality we've got a new shape
this is the you know one part of the
master slave dialectic that everybody
loves to talk about all the time right
because that's the most important idea
in hegel and giving a little bit of
joking there because obviously it's not
the most important idea but a lot of
people these days act as if it is
but then the slave develops right within
the dialectic and the master becomes
kind of in
this inert consumeristic enjoyment
functionary who doesn't develop any
further and so what do we have there
again
the principal is not allowed to be
isolated and some progress happens
and then after that of course you know
hegel devotes much more discussion
in the self-consciousness section to
what stoicism
skepticism the unhappy consciousness
and each one of those is supposed to be
you know a totality that develops its
own totality
takes a principle or principles
sometimes
works them out applies them figures out
what the hell they mean
in in you know making them actual and
then
understands that well now we're at the
point where we can you know
look at the book and we've got the map
of it in the table of contents and we
can kind of keep it all
stuck in our head hopefully and we can
see all these shapes leading into each
other
so he says gathering and holding
together
all these moments within itself it
advances within this total wealth of its
actual spirit
and all its particular moments take and
receive in common
the into themselves at the like
determinateness of the whole
each of them exists and each of them is
part of the whole this self-certain
spirit and its movement
is their true actuality it's what they
were without realizing it this entire
time
they are what they are by being within
the complex
of what's being studied
so he says um is their true actuality
the being in and for itself which
belongs to each moment so
you know in a way what's been happening
is each of these moments presenting
itself as a totality
has parasitically relied upon the hole
that it's been more or less ignoring in
order so it can have its own particular
totality
when it's really part of a larger
totality
and it's a part of a totality along each
of these
series or rows of development and but
it's also so within spirit
as a whole itself so he says
while the previous single series in its
advance marked the retrograde
retrogressive steps in it by
nodes but continued again from them in a
single
line so here we've got series
oh yeah right we've got nodes
knowledge right each of these is a a
node
or a knot if you want to tran you know
sort of almost transliterate it
each of them is broken and instead of
simply
there being a line going this way each
of them is a line
leading into what he calls a bundle
or in hegel's term bund right he says
it's broken at these nodes all these
universal moments falls apart in too
many lines
gathered up into a single bundle at the
same time combined symmetrically
so that the similar differences in which
each particular moment took shape
within itself meet together now this is
a this is difficult to visualize and i'm
certainly not going to attempt to do
justice to it here but the bund is not
just like a
bucket into which all of this stuff
falls like you know
somebody's shaking a tree and you know
the fruit falls
into the bucket no each of these is a
way in which they're all connected with
each other now
and that's what spirit has been able to
do
what does this have to do with religion
actually not that much
at this very second but immediately
after that
he's going to talk about how religion
fits in here
in the next you know section of this
paragraph he says
however it is self-evident from the
whole exposition now
self-evident from the whole ex position
that's that's a bit of a stretch there
hegel isn't it but
let's go on uh of the how this
coordination of the general directions
here represented is to be understood so
that it's superfluous to remark
that these differences are to be grasped
essentially only as moments of the
development not as parts
in actual spirit their attributes each
of these
are attributes of its
substance what's what's substance the
spirit as
you know spirit certain of itself the
true actuality
the being in and for itself of all these
things it is their
substance but in religion and now what
we mean here is in religion
at the point where we're beginning our
study of religion not at the end point
of religion
not the product the final state of
religion but religion
where we are it is a subject
now what kind of subject is it an acting
subject
is it like subjectivity no
subject in relation to predicate meaning
it is what we're talking about
and we're predicating we're saying
things about
something what is that something the
divine god
spirit this conglomeration here
of the most important stuff the totality
of everything and so he says in religion
they are only predicates of the subject
similarly all forms in general are
certainly in themselves or forests
contained in spirit
as regards spirit sexuality the main
point is solely which determinateness
is explicit for it in its consciousness
in which determinateness it has
expressed itself or in which shape it
knows its essence
so what we're going to have here is
within religion
things like this each shape we're going
to have to look at
one at a time we're not going to just
engage in some
big picture generalization about
religion we need to look at religions
and how each of them understands
the what the holy the divine the eternal
whatever we're going to call it the
essential the victims vason leakes right
and how the person is oriented towards
that so there's going to be a lot of
different conceptions of essentially god
or the divine coming in here
being developed in this way and that's
why we're going to now have another
linear progression going through the
religion section
you